chaoui monseigneur stream prince
raccompagnait c'est honnête marionnettes
chez son père protéger la des voleurs et
des charlatans de tout poil je m'en vais
lui faire cadeau de ces cinq pièces d'or
et il me déplairait fort que quelqu'un
l'ait lui dérobe
je vous remercie infiniment zadar en or
monseigneur m'en passer c'est fini allez
on sait foyer prudhomme patron vos
désirs sont des z'arts formes souples
quelques jolies jolies promenades qui va
faire en austral compagnie entre de
bonnes mains
alors dit moi chers enfants
que vas tu faire des jeux les pièces
d'or pour commencer je vais acheter un
magnifique mantois mon père m'a
entièrement doublé d'or et d'argent qui
se fermera avec de bière pression et
moelleux porter hiver comme été après
damas quoi qu'est ce qu'il y en aurait
un
ce nom je dînais qu'il ne restera plus
rien en poche des cinq misérables série
5 musées ou bhl ce gain de 4 sous
khémisset dommage quand on pense que tu
voulais en avoir des centaines sans
peine mieux que ça des 50 md matin des
dizaines des milliers d'e mails ans je
viens même plus exactement autant que
moi c'est très décourageant et au total
douze morts alors comment je pourrais
avoir plus de pièces d'or au du pigeon
va mordre l'âme si tu y as est
diaboliquement ça dans l'âge il tâtera
pitot
il y à une prairie magique connu sous le
nom en général on y fait des miracles
quand excavation dans le sol un petit
rond mais qu'au fond du trou en question
il plante ascione ces pièces d'or et que
c'est agroalimentaire à rosas abonde a
soigneusement 12 lendemain il retrouvera
l'endroit même un arbre aux branches
couvertes de pièces d'or dit vous voulez
bien emmené dans ce show miraculeuse
s'il vous plaît que toi